للمره الثانيه في ظرف وجهز ظهرت الى جانب
والدها في موعد عسكري جو ايه الطفله
الثانيه لكيم البالغه من العمر 10 سنوات
كل الاخبار الخاصه بكوريا الشماليه اصبحت
محور اهتمامها ممسكه بذراع والدها ومرتديه
معطفا اسود مثله تماما ملامحها تشبهه حد
التطابق فهي ابنته المدلله والتي وصفتها
وسائل الاعلام الكوريه الشماليه بانها
الاقرب الى قلبه من بين ابنائه الثلاثه
مستخدمه تعابير الابنه العزيزه ومحبوبتكم
ظهرت شو ايه وهي تقف الى جانب الزعيم
المثير للجدل في منتصف صف من الجنود امام
صاروخ ضخم موضوع فوق شاحنه اطلاق فيما
بدات في صور اخرى وهي تصفق للجنود
والعلماء وسائل اعلام كوريا جنوبيه سبق
وتكهنت بان للزعيم الكوري الشمالي ثلاثه
اطفال وان الطفل الاول ذكر بينما ثالث
انثى
وكانت الابنه المحبوبه ظهرت للمره الاولى
الاسبوع الماضي عندما نشرت وسائل الاعلام
الكوريه الشماليه صورا لها ممسكه بيد
والدها خلال اطلاق هو سونج 17
الظهور الثاني لجوء اثار التكهنات
المتعلقه بانتقال السلطه مستقبلا في كوريا
الشماليه
فيما راى خبراء ان كيم اراد الدعايه
لصاروخه الجديد من خلال الجيل الجديد
مضيفين انه سيواصل تقديم ابنته في مناسبه
العده كاداه للدعايه